we need you to hope hey youtubers it's
Charlie so Halloween just got a little
bit more awesome we got an x-men days of
future past trailer to talk about I've
already done a spoiler video for the
movie so let's just talk about some of
the most important bits in this trailer
and then I'll do a review as we've seen
the trailer this is a big call to action
for Professor Xavier this is a big
departure from a lot of the other x-men
movies because Professor Xavier is
always the one to call others to action
Bryan Singer some of the actors actually
refer to this movie as being like three
movies in one essentially it's a movie
in this post-apocalyptic future where
sentinels have taken over everything and
then it's a time travel story where
Wolverine goes back in time and then
it's an x-men story back in the 70s
Wolverine is basically trying to get
Professor X and Magneto to join forces
against this new threat played by Game
of Thrones Peter Dinklage he's playing
Bolivar Trask and he's essentially the
one that created the Sentinels and if
you saw the 90s cartoon then you've seen
sentinels before they're man-made
machines that basically just hunt down
the mutants and mass well let's talk
about new characters in the trailer
first there's Bing Bing fan who plays
blink that's basically a teleport person
not like kitty pryde she basically blink
and teleport across vast distances then
there's booboo Stewart as warpath Omar
sy as Bishop Adan canto is sunspot and
then obviously Peter Dinklage is Bolivar
Trask he's basically the big dawn of
this movie one person that we did not
see in the trailer that is in the movie
is Evan Peters as Quicksilver there are
also some other easter eggs in there too
if you remember at the end of that third
x-men movie the one that everyone's
trying to forget there's essentially a
romance between Bobby and Kitty Pryde it
looks like they're actually continuing
that storyline it looks like they're
basically a couple in this
post-apocalyptic future but honestly I
think the thing we need to talk about
most though is the tone of this trailer
I don't know about you guys but
personally it feels like a really sad
x-men movie really sad x-men movie might
not sound super exciting at first but
essentially bryan singer is one of the
best ensemble directors out there so i'm
really interested to see how he brings
these two x-men cast together I think
that'll be a big part of the fun of the
movie is just seeing the two generations
of x-men and work together like you can
see in the scene here there's
essentially a scene where old professor
xavier talks a young professor xavier
but some of the new things that we've
learned from the trailer that i didn't
discuss in my previous videos this is
kind of the alternate timeline version
of this x-men story so essentially this
post-apocalyptic future is like a
worst-case scenario for the x-men and it
looks like in the 70's past of this
movie the magneto basically took this
much darker path and Professor Xavier
essentially just hid out in his basement
while all this Sentinel business was
going on in the real world so basically
Bolivar Trask use the craziness of
magneto to create this Sentinel program
and it went horribly horribly wrong and
Professor Xavier basically didn't join
the fight till was much too late so
essentially this movie is basically
trying to erase that and get Professor
Xavier to join the fight sooner and kind
of call magneto down but let me know
your thoughts are on the trailer and
which new characters are you most
excited to see I think sunspot is really
critical to like the time-travel
mechanism of this so I'm interested to
see how that works but obviously that's
the least important part of the movie
the most important part is what happens
when Wolverine goes back and what he
changes if there's anything you saw on
the trail of the youth I was really
important that I didn't include in the
video be sure to write in the comments
I'll also be doing tons of x-men videos
between now and the end of May whenever
the movie premieres be sure to subscribe
to get those too overall I'm really
excited to see the movie I love Bryan
Singer movies he does ensemble films
really really great if you want to see
what it might look like watch the usual
suspects obviously it's a totally
different movie but it'll give you an
idea about how large cast work together
really really well in the meantime if
you want more spoilers for days of
future past you can click here to watch
that video i did a while ago it's a lot
of fun the movie is really great and you
can click here to watch the full
comic-con panel they talk about the
movie and they actually have the entire
cast of both generations of x-men on
stage at once it's on the camera almost
couldn't fit them all on stage at once
it's really really cool but anyway happy
Halloween thank you so much for watching
see you guys tomorrow high fives